nous nous avions plus de 315 candidat et
candidate du parti populaire à travers
le pays
ils ont fait preuve d'un courage et
d'une passion extraordinaire est
remarquable en défendant nos principes
et nos valeurs
ils ont fait malgré des attaques
honteuse de la part de nos opposants ils
ont fait d'immenses sacrifices
personnels pour offrir aux électeurs
canadiens une option fondée sur des
principes différente de toutes les
autres options des partis politiques
et laissez-moi vous dire qu'ils n'ont
pas fait ça pour rien ils ont construit
les fondations d'un mouvement qui ne
fait que commencer
[Applaudissements]
d des centaines de milliers de canadiens
ont donné leur appui au parti populaire
aujourd'hui nous sommes le parti qui
grandit le plus vite dans l'histoire
canadienne et nous allons continuer de
grandir au cours des prochains mois et
années